[Music]  Pandora is home to all manner of animals  there's stacks racks and various things  I call jazz cuz I don't know their help  we play near games my dude don't kill  things with I'm on camera  Oh in the majestic expansive sands of a  world like Pandora we must do everything  in our power to protect the flora and  fauna from the bandits and sometimes  fault hunters that would damage them  listen please a chance like this is  gonna come around again do not [ __ ] this  up for us don't you do that I went to  bat for you at the network you shoot at  everything you film for a lot of people  hiring camera crews that is a deal  breaker but not for me I believe in you  [Applause]  please we don't say those words around  here anymore because it might cause you  a slight case of the dismembered heads  will be yet see a spider ant a trash  feeder time will tell  all we ever set out to do was become  monstrously famous with minimal effort  but